pour les fêtes de fin d'année dreux à un
invité de marque
c'est pas tous les jours ces dix aurait
l'occasion vous à faire sur le fauteuil
du terme à l'étang le beffroi de la
ville on s'empresse d'avoir sa photo
avec le père noël
c'est bien pour les enfants oui ça leur
fait plaisir de été bien sage et votre
fille
évidemment pour distribuer du bonheur
gratuitement aux habitants la ville a
mis la main au porte-monnaie 180000
euros pour 20 jours d'animations et
d'illumination en tout genre cet
investissement est deux fois plus
important que l'an passé et il porte ses
fruits
on veut que dreux devienne une référence
régionale pour l'animation de fêtes de
fin d'année et de noël ici dans notre
ville aujourd'hui on a constaté que 40%
des gens qui venaient pour cet événement
à dreux viennent des yvelines c'est un
signal très fort pour nous parce que ça
veut dire qu'on arrive à attirer des
gens qui m'ont un peu plus d'argent
cadres eux et qui vient découvrir la
ville la magie de noël opère donc eu
jusque dans le tiroir caisse des
commerçants les touristes attirés par
les illuminations s'arrête et consomment
dans ces chalets mise à disposition
gratuitement les exposants mesure la
chance qu'ils ont de pouvoir vendre
leurs produits
quand la plupart des marchés de noël
sont annulés sans marché de noël c'est
un chiffre d'affaires d'un peu plus de
5000 euros qui serait qu'ils seraient
pas fait sur sur le week-end donc c'est
très très important tournée on se
demandait comment on allait pouvoir
exposer et à nos clients en fait à nos
consommateurs
composé de nos petites mains et puis bah
là ils nous ont appelés on est ravi
d'être là
grâce aux dizaines de kilomètres de
l'irlande qui illumine la ville
le père noël ne manquera pas son
atterrissage à dreux cette année voilà
qui ravit les petits comme les plus
grands acquis un moment de rêve et de
féerie fait du bien en cette fin d'année